io sono medico ma stasera vi parlo da
paziente vi racconto la storia che è
capitata a me ma potrebbe capitare fate
pure tutti gli scongiuri
a ciascuno di voi perché ogni anno in
italia 150 mila persone arrivano nei
pronto soccorsi con trauma cranico
prendono una botta di queste una
ristretta maggioranza circa un 3 400
persone hanno problemi poi di memoria io
sono uno di quelli
il 31 maggio del 2013 io facevo il
primario del pronto soccorso di nodi
adesso sono il primario del pronto
soccorso di codogno mi trovano con la
macchina capotata dietro l'ospedale di
pavia
io abito a pavia siamo in lombardia
pavia e lodi distano circa 45 chilometri
mi trovano con la macchina girata ho
abbattuto un garrè l'unica testimone ha
visto una macchina blu sbandare e poi
cadere e rimango poche ore in coma ben
poco meno di sei ore
quando arrivate perché a questo punto
potreste essere uno dei 150mila ri
continuate a fare gli scongiuri
chiaramente quando è arrivato in pronto
soccorso e prendete una botta in testa
il medico vi chiede qual è il tuo ultimo
ricordo bene a questa domanda quando io
mi sono svegliato imbragato con ero
finito come codice rosso perché ero in
coma nel pronto soccorso quindi nello
shock room fili catetere
ovviamente mi sveglio e alla domanda
rispondo l'unica l'ultima cosa che io mi
ricordo e che appena accompagnato a casa
mio figlio alla scuola mio figlio
tommaso che oggi proprio oggi compie 8
anni
piccolo particolare il mio ultimo
ricordo era nella data che vedete il 25
ottobre del 2000
e lì inizia una saga dei disguidi una
saga delle delusioni una saga delle
illusioni che continuerà avanti perché
l'altra cosa che ti chiedono è vuoi
vedere i tuoi familiari
caspita se voglio vedere i miei
familiari mi a tua moglie la vuoi vedere
certo che lo voglio vedere mia moglie
questa è una fotografia di mia moglie
che si chiama maria assunta perché è
nata il 15 agosto del 2001 e successi
perché nata il 15 agosto del 1961 non
era prevista è questa però avete avete
assistito a qualcosa di assolutamente
sano succede anche agli amici ma succede
a tutti è una fotografia che avevamo
fatto in montagna nell'estate del 2000
un attimino prima e io mi immagino che
entri questa persona e di entracque sta
qui allora lo dico e lo ripeto spesso mi
rivolgo ai maschi mentite sempre anche
fuori dal coma
perché la prima cosa che io dico poi poi
quando leggere quando vi farò leggere il
referto perché poi c'è tutta la storia
capirete perché sono ironico autoironico
il mio hanno spiegato i relatori prima
di me parte del mio della mia sostanza
grigia non è propriamente come dovrebbe
essere e io dico a mia moglie di con
miseria quante rughe e sotto il collo
non me l'ha ancora perdonato dopo tre
anni e mezzo e quindi mentite mentite
mentite e mi chiedono vuoi vedere i tuoi
bambini tuoi figli nella mia memoria un
bimbo di 8 anni e uno di 11
io dico ma siete matti sono qui tutto è
pieno di fili tenere tutti poi i bambini
piccoli non possono entrare in ospedale
perché questa era il mio ricordo di
tommaso nell'estate prima tommaso quello
che compiva otto anni nel 2001
nell'estate del 2001 con in braccio un
micio e me lo ritrovo così come la vista
a tommaso ha fatto una battuta
bellissimo papa dal micio alla miccia si
è vero questo però per dire che cosa che
come cambia voi immaginatevi le
aspettative di un papa che al in banche
si aspetta di vedere un bimbo davanti
invece si trova un adulto cisternino
siamo più vicino
questa è l'estate del 2001 poco prima
che tommaso compisse i famosi i famosi 8
anni questa è la piazza ci stavano
guardando una lavanda voi sapete chi è
stato a cisternino che c'è il palco con
boccerà perlomeno ancora adesso non lo
so io i bambini questo e tommaso in
un'altra fotografia gli portavo in
braccio
adesso sono loro che portano in groppa a
me ve la ricordate
io mi sono addormentata con questa e mi
sono svegliato con questo
ve lo ricordate i telefoni facevano ss
senza corde lawley vecchio non olivetti
ma i telefoni nel 2001 telefonavano e
mandava gli sms da forse un anno un anno
e mezzo
adesso i telefoni touchscreen
io mi sono svegliato senza sapere che
cosa fosse il touchscreen riabilitazione
lunga due anni ci ho messo ho provato a
fare un po così apprendere guarda sulla
sinistra c'è un cervello e questa è una
pet di un cervello normale di un
paziente a metà e di un paziente con
l'alzheimer
questa è la pet che ho provato a trovare
di un demente questa è la mia eta se voi
guardate i referti parla di atrofia
atrofia corticale in varie parti
questa è il referto che io ho dovuto per
correttezza consegnare la mia azienda
allora voi vi fareste curare da un
medico che a questo referto che ha delle
atrofie nel cervello perché io volevo
ritornare una volta che mi sono
svegliato a fare il medico
sulla base di quel referto che cosa mi è
stata proposta la pensione d'invalidità
potete immaginare cosa uno vada incontro
è che cosa 1 paesi io ci sono arrivato è
lì vicino
la mia auto ironia di adesso e l'effetto
di quella di quel referto pet che vi ho
fatto vedere la mia azienda da primario
mi ha mandato a fare il bidello perché
uno con quel referto non poteva far
altro se non il bidello
spero non ci siano bidelli non si
offendano ma non è la mia opinione
e l'opinione dei miei direttori allora
senza offesa ancora per i bidelli di
dalian tanto tempo libero
io lo avevo perlomeno cosa ho fatto
ho provato a ribaltare le regole che mi
venivano imposte ho detto ah sì tu dici
che io sono quel referto e io ti
dimostro
quando recuperando che io non sono quel
referto io sono qualche cosa in più
io sono una persona non un paziente una
persona studi in paris che ci sono delle
robe che si chiamano brainshake in che
ti spiegano un sacco di cose ma ci sono
degli antidoti a tutto questo i farmaci
io non ho vergogna a dire ho assunto
antidepressivi sono stato in
psicoterapia perché altrimenti non sarei
qui a raccontarvelo ma fondamentalmente
gli antidoti per la mia situazione sono
questi è la famiglia e gli amici
famiglia e amici
questa è la società scientifica che ho
scoperto di avere fondato e questo è
quello che io la cosa a cui home disco
la serenità che auguro a tutti ma
occorre un pochettino a volte per
arrivarci questa è una fotografia che mi
hanno fatto perché il mio caso poi
andato a conoscenza del mondo senza
scomodare platone con la caverna un
tunnel a un sempre una luce alla fine di
questo tunnel
a patto e questo è il messaggio che vi
voglio lasciare che vorrei che voi e
ricordaste visto che stiamo parlando di
memoria e che adesso mi ha cambiato
completamente la vita da medico e
utilizzerò questi ultimi minuti per
raccontarvelo
io non sono sue twitter quello della
saga
ma cos'è giusto e twitter io non sono su
twitter perché io mi sono addormentato
che con la lira e col telefono che
faceva gli sms i miei figli mi aiutano
molto e mi hanno aiutato molto per lo
dicevo prima
ma il mio motto adesso è io non sono il
mio referto perché questo è quello che
fa la differenza nel trattare le persone
in ogni pazienti
io non ho davanti un valore di una
glicemia io davanti una persona che ha
il diabete e tante altre robe
io non ho davanti
io non ho davanti la pec di un demente
io davanti una persona che è in grado di
fare certe cose o meno questo non
importa perché la parola magica che io
adesso utilizzo e che pretendo che gli
altri utilizzino con me la esiguo dai
miei collaboratori
ma è la easy go da tutti e questa tutta
questa storia l'ho raccontato in un
libro non vedete qui che si chiama meno
12 scritto con pierangelo sapegno che un
giornalista della stampa perché mi sono
reso conto di una cosa
all'inizio non volevo perché anche stare
qui raccontarsi non è sempre semplice ma
è fondamentale perché se vuoi che la
gente ricordi
prima deve capire e l'unico modo che hai
per farglielo capire
e semplicemente raccontare una storia
[Musica]